[Music]
when professional boxers win a title
they're crowned the champ and rewarded
with a belt to be worn around the waist
each international organization
Commission's a belt that's
custom-designed to its specifications
and prominently features the
organization's logo in the belt central
medallion these boxing championship
belts are entirely handcrafted the
laterals the side pieces flanking the
ornate Center plate are sometimes
engraved with the fighters portrait when
a Boxing Association Commission's a new
design the company's artisans prepare a
sketch for each piece following the
sketch they sculpt a clay model from
that they cast a plaster model then a
metal model for finding the sculpture at
each step
artisans use the final metal model to
produce a rubber mold which is used to
cast the piece in white metal the
extracted castings are quite rough so
the workshops craftsmen use files
chisels and automated tools to refine
the shape
some of the devices and techniques are
routinely used by jewelers while others
were designed specifically for this
purpose
[Music]
once the intricate details are completed
the team files down rough spots along
the perimeter
the belts feature a three-dimensional
sculpture of an eagle fused to the
center plate an artisan heats the wings
with an open flame to make them pliable
then he bends them to render the Eagle
more lifelike
[Music]
every piece must be meticulously hand
polished on a buffing wheel this
prepares the metal to be plated with
gold or rhodium the piece is
electroplated with copper then nickel
then 18 karat gold the nickel carries
the shine through to the surface after a
thorough buffing on the surface the
pieces are embellished with crystals
into molded cavities
[Music]
sometimes a championship winner may
order precious stones such as diamonds
and rubies to replace the crystals
depending on their preference a team of
enamel errs paints the finished pieces
with jewelry grade enamel this requires
a steady hand and close attention to
detail once the piece is painted it's
put into an oven to bake the enamel
[Music]
the belt strap is made of high-grade
bonded leather a craftsman traces a belt
template in the leather then cuts it out
with a knife then they adhere the strap
to leather or high grade vinyl the
designer sews the straps lining
separately stitching black spandex over
a faux fur backing and attaching the
authenticity label which bears the belt
serial number this distinguishes it from
cheaply made copies the craftsman
attaches leather high grade vinyl piping
to the strap perimeter he places a brand
sticker on the back next to an inscribed
tribute to the originator of the modern
boxing belt they adhere the lining then
after smoothing out the layers of the
belt with a hammer the designer stitches
the lining to the strap some belts have
buckles others hook and loop fasteners
which are stitched to the strap at the
same time as the lining
[Music]
once the belt is finished the center
plate and laterals are attached it's
essential to wear gloves while doing
this to protect the pristine surface the
final step is to place an engravable
brass plate into each lateral then the
championship belt is delivered in a
handcrafted protective case for a knock
out presentation